what if I asked you about that
particular belief but then I said well
do you want to bet on it it forces you
into the world of probability and real
makes you realize that maybe I'm not so
sure I'm Nick Gillespie and today we are
talking with Annie Duke
she's the duchess of poker in 2004 annie
who is now retired from professional
poker but she won a gold bracelet World
Series of Poker and she's the author of
a really great autobiography or memoir
it's called how I raised folded bluffed
flirted first and won millions at the
World Series of Poker and today she also
has a background in cognitive science
and that is doing a lot of work on that
and has a book that is in in the works
about this we're gonna be talking about
poker psychology linguistics prohibition
and Donald Trump because in 2009 Annie
finished second overall to Joan Rivers
on Celebrity Apprentice and so she may
well have some personal insights and
animus towards the next president or
possibly the last president of the
United States
and you have a connection to
Pennsylvania you did graduate work here
in the psychology department or
cognitive linguistics at University of
Pennsylvania uh yeah actually I'm dating
my father grew up in West Philly and I
think he's a great example of what makes
America great his both his parents
emigrated from Eastern Europe at the
turn of the last century and his father
had a sixth grade education and my
father has a PhD so I you but now this
is Camille poly I said yesterday Western
civilization is declining and your
grandfather had a sixth grade education
your father's a PhD and let's face it
you didn't finish the slide I still have
a chance though he didn't late in life
so so he got his master's early and I
tied him on that though um yeah at
anyway but he so he went to West Philly
high and then made his way on to
eventually making his way to Harvard
though and then I so I mean
those ties to Philadelphia then I was
five years at University of Pennsylvania
in the psychology department doing my
PhD work and almost anything what and
and it's also it's a great story
especially given the academic job market
you left
I mean you stopped doing work because
she started playing poker professionally
right yeah basically what happened was
at the end of my time there I had you
know my job table talks lined up uh and
I actually got ill so I needed to take a
leave of absence so during that time I
started playing poker and I in the first
month that I played poker
I made twenty eight hundred dollars
which I think the starting salaries of
the jobs that I were looking at we're
right in the twenty three twenty five
range and that it you know and it seemed
like wow that was pretty good money
aside from the fact that actually really
was completely in love with the game
yeah talk about what what drew you to it
and you also have a brother who is a
poker player um y-you know what happened
that it about you and we're also uh how
many of you play poker or watch it on a
lot of them play like we have
demonstration last night you know we're
in a kind of Golden Age of Poker and
recognizing poker maybe in the way
bridge I was talking about this with
some people earlier a couple of decades
ago bridge was seen as a fun and intense
and exciting and competitive game poker
seems to be occupying a lot of that
space even more what drew you to it and
why do you think it's you know so big so
I think that what drew me to it was I
the fact that it's a game and in the
true sense of what a game is so let me
just explain
so chess is not actually by definition a
game and the reason that chess is not by
definition a game is because there is no
hidden information um so you can see all
the pieces right so what you can imagine
with chess is assuming you had enough
computing power you could actually
calculate out what all the possible
moves are and computers have gotten
pretty good at that we have big blue and
that's why computers actually beat human
being now with relative ease at a game
like chess and that game in the
colloquial sense not in the technical
sense in order something for something
to be technical
there has to be an element of hidden
information so in poker obviously you
have hidden cards right so we can't see
the other players cards which creates a
really interesting decision making
problem because you're living in this
world of uncertainty around what you
have so I've got to sort of figure out
what cards do I think you have by
watching the way that you're behaving
and then you add in this great element
of LA right that even if I were to be
able to determine exactly what you had
and I knew for example that I was 80% to
win the hand and so I decided to play I
would still lose 20% of the time and we
don't know which thing is gonna happen
on that particular iteration I just know
percentage-wise what will happen so this
creates a really interesting decision
making problem in fact it's so
interesting that the whole field of game
theory which is an arm of economics was
based on a simplified game of poker john
von neumann who is the father of modern
game theory as well as the father of the
modern shooter by the way and in 1950 he
was named high magazine most brilliant
mathematician of the time a lot of
people don't know who he is because he
didn't have funny hair and an accent
like well he did have an accent but he
didn't have the funny hair and the
bicycle that Einstein had um but he he
actually was an avid poker player loved
poker and when he was thinking about
game theory he sort of took a simplified
version of poker and based it on that so
what we can imagine is if game theory
which is the study of human
decision-making in general is based on
poker and you have this person who's
coming from cognitive science which is
the study of human decision-making gets
thrown into a poker game think about
that collision right so for me that was
like oh my god this is incredible
and you made bunny and I made like yes
and I did well for myself I would have
stayed if I weren't making money my next
question is so and you've already I
think suggest that some of them what are
the life lessons that play that you can
sharpen by playing poker and thinking
about poker and the kind of those
probabilistic questions it raises the
decision-making we talked a little bit
before we got up here about decision
trees and kind of critical thinking
skills and and talk about your work that
you're doing to kind of push that along
I well what life lessons can poker teach
us I would say like all of them but for
actual I mean the the thing is that um I
you know game theories really studying
the interactions of multiple people
under conditions of uncertainty over
time doesn't that sound like what our
life is right so a poker can really
teach us a lot about this and one of the
great things with poker is that it's a
very tight and closed feedback loop what
I mean by that is that the decisions and
action are tied very very closely in
time to the outcome great a hand of
Poker takes two minutes unless you have
someone who's annoyingly slow with you
at the table
so I've been chased off of poker tables
in Atlantic's from Atlantic City to Los
and I'm not even allowed on the indiana
river boats on the ohio river so but
even if you have someone who's kind of
slow maybe it takes three minutes yeah
right so so you're getting this this
feedback super super fast the other
thing is that it's one of the few places
where your competitor is sitting across
from you and there's a direct exchange
that happens at the end of each hand
this creates is a lot of emotion around
the decisions and what basically happens
is that you really can see in a very
very magnified way the way that our
rationalities play into our
decision-making so I don't know how many
of you are familiar with these book you
know there's very popular books out
there like Thinking Fast and Slow
predictably irrational you know it's all
these things in behavioral economics
which is really saying we're not really
rational actors it turns out that
there's evolute you know we're sort of
from an evolutionary standpoint it was
rational behaviors that occurred but not
necessarily in a modern world it's kind
of like we're I mean our brain and it's
not a computer but it's like a complete
computer that is soaking in an ivory
liquid that is emotion right and and not
only that that's so true and by the way
I got $5 for mentioning ivory liquid but
I also matched with Palmolive and so I
so what I like to say is we have this
humongous you know with this big animal
brain that's old and makes decisions
about running away from lion right
and then we have this little tiny thin
layer of cortex which was essentially
invented just for us but it's small and
it has to it has to deal with all of our
deliberative decision-making right and
it's very stressed it's got a lot to do
and there's not much of it right so most
of our decisions are happening in this
other part of our brain so when you play
poker you can really see these kinds of
irrational decisions coming to the fore
and then what's really wonderful about
it is you can say what have the top
slice of poker players done because
there's only a little top thin slice of
them who are really persisting and doing
well in the game what are they doing
that's building walls around those kinds
of behaviors that other people aren't
necessarily implementing and then you
can just take that out into well since
we know that this is really
decision-making distilled and like a
petri dish we can now take that out into
the world and take those lessons with us
and you give a concrete example say in a
bit of a poker situation where I guess
the question is not leech out emotion
but to control it or make sure it's not
controlling you but from from a poker
game to a real-life situation like have
with sorry I think that's a great
question I have to think about all the
examples so I'll give you a really easy
one that you all understand and you'll
see very quickly how it plays out and
pretty much everything so one of the
puzzles for me when I started playing
poker was that when I was in graduate
school I learned that learning occurs
under conditions where there's lots and
lots of decisions and actions tied
closely and time to feedback they're
very simple
it's kind of what Pavlov taught us right
with his dogs then the bells and the
salivating okay so I understood that so
now I go and I sit down and I play poker
and I say oh hold on a second there's
lots and lots of decisions and actions
pide very closely in time to feedback
and yet I can win at the game right and
I'm watching people make the same
mistakes over and over again for like 20
years so that that was very puzzling to
me because of my academic background
right I was confused by that so one of
the first things I noticed that really
explained that for me was I said
what are people doing with the feedback
they're getting cuz that's really where
they're gonna learn from right so so
what what happens when they get a bad
outcome they say I got so unlucky
because remember this is an ambiguous
world that we're making decisions then
write this it's not chess where I can
say I moved my knight into the wrong
place with surety right I can say oh I
just got unlucky I was actually supposed
to win but the math was again right um
so I can say that I could have gotten
low what happens when they win I'm so
smart and brilliant player that ever
lived so what's happening they're
socializing their bad outcome and
they're privatizing their good outcomes
now this should be pretty familiar to
everybody right like I have a son who's
just finishing high school and my gosh
he has never come home with a bad grade
on a test where it wasn't because the
teachers really hard and the test was
really hard and he put things on the
test that weren't actually taught in
class and also the teacher really
doesn't like him and if I have any
questions about that I should just go
ask everyone in his class and they will
confirm that but when he gets a good
grade it's like mom I got a 95 I worked
so hard can we go out to dinner so and
we can see this in the election cycle
right it's like why am i doing poorly
it's their fault it and we can pick
right we can look at the sort of
spectrum and there's people on one side
of the aisle saying it's their fault
looking down from them and there's other
people saying it's their fault looking
up right but it's not your fault
right so this is very very very common
actually in one of the debates there was
something very funny um Chris Christie
said about Hillary Clinton and Benghazi
um don't you worry she you know she's
just saying that's not her fault but if
it had worked out she'd be the first one
to take credit for it right about five
minutes later he was asked about
Bridgegate to which he said oh I didn't
know anything about that that wasn't my
fault
um so you can see this this is really
everywhere out there in the world and
it's a really big problem talk a bit
about how you you've said that you've
learned from watching other players
succeed and fail and then and
there's you know learning how to become
multi-perspective I guess for that a $5
word or just saying like actually
recognizing you have limits the
knowledge and that you can gain from
understanding other people that's great
so that's actually part of the way that
you solve for the problem that I just
talked about so one of the things we
want to do is be really good
disconnectors of outcome and decision
right so we can do that through good
culture right so I had a wonderful group
of players around me who if I came and
just said oh I just got unlucky I would
be challenged but on that fact by them
right and they would say I'm not
interested in that if you just got
unlucky there's no learning to be had
from it what could you learn from the
hand so I had people helping me because
one of the things you learn is these
things are so deep within us we need
good culture and good social structure
around us to challenge us so I was
taught if I have nothing to say about
the hand besides I got unlucky or I'm so
great that I was I actually got very bad
social negative feedback from discussing
those kinds of hands with the people
around me I actually had to find
learning experiences so as I was doing
that and I was kind of learning from
these great players including my brother
Howard Lederer who's amazing um I found
myself thinking oh okay well so now I
kind of have this idea of what how
you're supposed to play and I sat down
at tables and people were not playing
according to what I had been told right
so my first instinct was to just assume
they were bad right just to say oh
they're bad because they're doing
something different than me they clearly
have no idea what they're doing well
taking the lessons of what my culture
was teaching me about trying to get more
deeply into that and not sort of going
with it what your first instinct is I
said a rule for myself well okay this
this seems like this is sort of in that
category so I'm gonna set a rule my job
if I see anybody at the table is to find
the one thing that they do better than I
do
because even if their overall a losing
player even if Oh most of the things
that they do are actually not the like
what the optimal strategy is there's
probably something they're doing that's
better than me and I've got to figure
without it about that in context of we
were discussing this just a couple
minutes ago but about a kind of
political information the political
frameworks issue were saying did what
what does a fox news watcher gain from
looking at MSNBC you know what how does
that factor into this idea of trying to
get outside of our immediate ocean so
you know so what happens is that what I
was falling prey to is really something
called confirmation bias so I had an
idea of how you were supposed to play
and if someone was falling out of that I
just assumed they were bad because that
confirmed my belief that I knew what I
was doing right it made me feel good
about myself
so if you think about this this is the
actions that we get all over the map and
you particularly see it with politics
and you particularly say it right now
cuz obviously emotions are running very
high and whenever emotions run high
explodes right so if I am a fox news
watcher I have certain beliefs about
politics right do I want someone to tell
me my beliefs are wrong no because that
makes me feel bad so what do I naturally
do I walk into an echo chamber and I go
and watch Fox News and they tell me all
the things that I already believe and I
feel really good about myself right
just like poker players uh the majority
of poker players didn't have the luck of
being forced into a good culture like I
was by my brother and this is what they
do
oh can you believe how bad that guy
played yeah he's horrible right and
that's literally what the conversation
is like as you're walking down the halls
right so I I recommend to people that
they do what I did at the poker table
right which I well I was lucky enough to
do with the poker if you are a Fox News
watcher go watch the Rachel Maddow Show
and don't watch it to yell at the TV and
scream about how wrong she is go watch
it with a group of your FoxNews friend
and come back and reconvene after I all
having watched Rachel Maddow and each of
you has to say the one thing that she
said that you agree with the one thing
that made you maybe rethink something
vice versa if you watched MSNBC go watch
Bill O'Reilly and figure out the thing
it is that he's saying that seems to
make some sense
I my particular news source a lot of my
new sources actually RealClearPolitics
why because if I read every single
article on there I get far right far
left libertarian everything because
they're just aggregating right across
the political spectrum and I think that
that makes us all better thinkers
because it forces us to put ourselves in
another view it forces us to realize
that the world is in black and white
it's not we're never a hundred percent
correct or zero percent correct it's
always how you obviously haven't heard
what my staff says about me an editorial
meeting that you're a hundred percent
correct or 0 what's Y euro it's always
zero and I was gonna say after you
instructed us to watch Rachel Maddow and
Bill O'Reilly for the first time I might
like public I will say just turn off the
TV no don't even read a book just take a
nap or something you know let me let me
try and put something of a libertarian
spin on what you're talking about
you know a lot of libertarian thought
and I I don't want to force a label on
you but if you want to talk about you
know what your personal ideology a lot
of libertarian thought and certainly
coming out of people like Friedrich von
Hayek it talks about it stresses the
limits of knowledge that knowledge is
real and it's cumulative and we could
learn more about the world we can learn
more about probabilities but ultimately
we know less at any given point and I
think this is the sum of what gone and
Adrian we're talking about in the
previous segment session we know less
than we think and we gained from having
overlapping frameworks by which to
understand the world we can challenge
our belief system so we understand we're
in a system and we're swimming in in
water that maybe is not the limit of the
world so you do a lot of work on
critical thinking this is this is your
that your big push you want to increase
critical thinking whether it's in the
c-suite or whether it's for lower-income
children who might not be exposed to
this type of stuff talk about you know
is there a libertarian edge to what
you're talking about here and then
particularly of getting younger people
to think critically with kind of
multiple frameworks work in a
pluralistic way that there is not one
final answer only one way of looking at
the world how was that going so I
co-founded a
nonprofit called how I decide and
basically the work so I do keynoting and
corporate retreats and consulting on
decision making and critical thinking
skills with executives and I then take
that into through how I decide creating
innovation both high-touch and high
scale products and interventions to
teach critical thinking and decision
skills with a focus on underserved youth
particularly middle schoolers although
we we serve some other people so I think
that the thing that you said in there
that's the most important is this idea
of probabilistic thinking right that
things aren't 100% true or 0% true and
that if we understand that that we're
sort of swimming in the waters of
uncertainty I think that we all become
better belief updaters and I think that
that's really where the core of the
problem is is that we aren't good belief
updaters and the reason is that we've
got this process in place we think that
the way that our beliefs our form are
that we hear something or read something
about something we then ponder it and
think about it and bet the information
and then we form a belief wrong order
exactly so what the way it actually
works is we hear something we believe it
and this has been shown in several
studies if anybody would there Dan
Gilbert is the place that you would go
look to find that um he wrote a book
called stumbling on happiness later but
his original work was on this I we hear
something we believe it and then if we
have the timer in collation we go and
check it out later on which mostly
actually doesn't happen the reason for
that is very simple
evolution likes to work with structures
that already exist because we can't take
our brains out of our head
and install a new iOS it doesn't work
that way um so how did we mostly form
beliefs well with our eyes right seeing
is believing I see a tree the tree
exists is there a reason for the middle
step of well let me vet whether this
tree exists not really cuz I already saw
it so um that's how our abstract belief
formation system works now what the
problem is is that once we form a belief
which we haven't vetted really well we
notice information that reinforces the
beliefs we don't tend to notice
information that discounts it and in
fact if we do if we are actually
presented with information
that does discount it we will do all
sorts of mental gymnastics to try to
discredit this you see this if you watch
the Eagles and the Cowboys play a game
and both fans come away and the refs
have cheated them which obviously is
impossible but that's what you do you're
noticing all the calls that go only
against your team and you're discounting
everything else that happens and because
you have a belief that the this is why
you lost and the rest are cheating you
right so what would happen instead if we
have a belief if we were forced to think
about it as if it were a bat which force
us into thinking about probability right
so um as an example I like to talk about
the fact I'm normally I would have
people raise their hand but we don't
have that here but there's a lot of
amputees thank you so people in general
have a belief about how you could
predict if a man will go bald and I'm
sure that all of you know this you look
at the mother's father the paternal
grandfather right and this is a very
commonly held belief you probably know
that right um so it turns out that
that's not actually just cut it with the
ad hominins so I it turns out that
that's not true actually that it's
actually a many many genes that are
involved in figuring out if a man's
gonna go bald and in fact many weddings
where we're going to talk about Trump at
the end but right now we're getting
there already
another really commonly held belief is
that if you want to figure out what your
dog's age is in human years you would
multiply each year that your dog has
lived by seven that's also not true cuz
it's not linear but these are beliefs
that are very commonly held that we
don't really question and we walk around
and declare them to be true and every
time we see a paternal grandfather who's
bald you say aha right and if you
they're not bald you just ignore it um
but what if what if I asked you about
that particular belief but then I said
well do you want to bet on it
all of a sudden you start saying well
now let me think about this for a second
where did I hear that what have I done
have I actually looked at the evidence
but you got to put some money on it now
right it forces you into the world of
probability and real it makes you
realize that maybe I'm not so sure and
it's a simple thing for a poker player
to think about because this is all I do
betting on on my confidence level about
what your hand is right so I walk around
in the world and I say well I think that
such-and-such is gonna happen but I'm
like 73% and that's sort of the normal
way that I talk what if you incorporated
that into the normal way that you talk
how wonderful that would be now if you
hear new information that contradicts
can't even contradict your belief it
just allows you to update your
percentage right so if I say oh you know
I read this really article really
interesting article about what would
happen if the minimum wage were raised
but I'm not an economist so my faith in
that given the source is like you know
I'm like 78 percent that a lot of what
was said in there was true
now if I read something else I can just
update that right I can say well now I'm
71 percent or now I'm 85 percent there
you're not living and wrong or right
anymore which is really beautiful but
the other thing is I serve you well when
I say I'm 80 percent because now you
understand well this is sort of where
I'm sitting and maybe we can explore
this together I invite you into a social
exploration of the belief and we'd all
be so much better off if we thought
about things that way did you comment
briefly and I know you're no longer kind
of working the I mean you you lobbied to
make online gambling or online I did it
one way but why why is card playing and
particularly things like poker y-you
know and given the way that you just I
think had a great you know way to take
its lessons to every aspect of our lives
why is it considered a fight because
gambling is considered advice in some
religious system so I think that is it
because it was perceived as a block or
or because it's great or I mean I guess
it's a combination and or it's just
somehow contravening a higher power so I
so it's not actually prohibited in the
Bible let me just say that there isn't a
prohibition against gambling in the
Bible but I as religious people remember
didn't they gamble for Jesus's close but
it was crap figured a lot of patience
the best odds in the house oh you know
they do it well if you play it correctly
it can't have the worst odds in the
house you actually have to play a good
strategy and you're still losing by the
way let me just say that I've found that
my whole life okay I can get you to
where you're losing less than less than
1% but that's the best I can do for you
so I think this speaks to the problem of
I think people are very uncomfortable
with uncertainty and uncomfortable with
kind of thinking probabilistically it's
why how I decide wants to really get
people to kids to be better
decision-makers so they grow up into
people who are ok with uncertainty
because what happens is that you've got
this stuff happening and people don't
really understand why it's happening and
it feels like blah right and somehow
that doesn't feel good to them what I do
in poker isn't luck in the long run I'm
just grinding out an edge like anybody
is if you open a business because soon
you're trying to grind out a positive
expectancy I hope some people think they
have that but they don't but whatever so
I think that that then got into this
world of like we want to protect people
from themselves because they're gonna
get involved in this thing that's just
love you know meanwhile lotteries seem
to be totally exempted from this whole
idea that that's immoral which I don't
even want to but um and I think that
it's that that there's this weird it's
like uncertain and we don't know and
that feels bad and it feels like it's
all just fate and people are gonna get
attracted to that and so we have to
protect them from that decision when
actually that would be a really good
life lesson for people it's actually
quite the opposite aside from the fact
that particularly poker in particular
and I think whether you have an edge or
not you should have the right to engage
in it regardless but poker in particular
is very odd because it's something where
you can actually there's a huge skill
element do you think you mentioned that
you have a son a lot of us have children
you know kids boys and girls are gaming
more and more and a lot of these games
are actually you know there are
percentage games is that helping create
you know add 10 years ago 20 years ago
people were complaining about gaming as
a you know as a horrific impact on kids
influence you think it's helping to
teach some of these lessons because
they're very complicated yeah so I'll
tell you how much I think that that
might be true part of what we've done it
how I decide is we funded a guy named
Adam Gaza Gaza Lee who is a
neuroscientist at UCSF at University of
California San Francisco and what he
does is create video games in order to
solve neurological issues where what he
says is that small molecules medicines
are very blunt instruments right they
kind of work across the brain um he's
not saying eliminate those but he's
saying maybe you can get in there with a
more precision instrument and actually
work on the circuitry that's actually
being affected and whatever the
cognitive deficit might be his original
work was on something called neuro Racer
I highly recommend you look at it he
made the cover of nature looking at 70
year olds and getting them to perform in
certain areas of cognitive decline as if
they were now 25 year old um through the
use of a video game he's got that now
with the FDA trying to get FDA approval
for the first time for a video game I
think it's incredibly innovative so what
we're doing at how I decide is thinking
about something called delay of
gratification which has to do with
temporal discounting which is how good
are you at balancing out your future
utility with your present um so if I
offer you a hundred dollars day or a
hundred and thirty dollars in a year
which one are you taking right and I can
sort of figure out how much you value
the future over the present now it turns
out that this is very predictive of
success for kids if I take four-year-old
and I say do you want a marshmallow now
or you can sit with that marshmallow for
15 minutes and if you don't eat it
you'll get a second marshmallow about
15% of four-year-olds are able to resist
eating the marshmallow and it's very
predictive of all sorts of thing like
how you do in your job or your marriage
or whatever so we know that if we can
train up this delay of gratification
that it can have all sorts of good
results you can imagine it would make
you a better study or and may be
snapchatting less right so that would be
good so we're working with him to create
a video game for 12 to 16 year olds that
would actually specifically promote this
issue of delay of gratification we're
about to go into piloting we're about
nine months the project I put six months
of piloting and then six months of
testing including EEG and fMRI data to
go along with it so you can see what's
happening in the brain and then
validated batteries to see what's
happening in behavior and work
crossing our fingers for great results
that we love videogames as tools to
teach decision-making
you know yesterday when Camille Poli was
talking I asked her to make a case for
the humanities to people who might be
more interested in science you have a
science background but you also majored
as an undergrad in English and talk a
little bit about how you know facility
with language reading literature and
learning to write actually help you get
to where you are I think having
knowledge is great but if you can't
communicate it then the knowledge is
sitting in your head and people don't
understand you so what I found was that
so my dad was the English teacher um so
I kind of had that kind of growing up
and wanting to follow in his footsteps a
little bit one of my two majors at
Columbia was English English Lit I did
science as my second one
so when I got to graduate school I got
funneled in with nobody who had ever
been in an English class except for it
happened to maybe have been a
requirement to get your degree right so
these weren't people who were sitting in
the humanity um and I had been prattling
the two worlds now in graduate school
everything is done by Blue Book si and
lo and behold I sort of got like that
extra half grade not because my
knowledge was better than their it's not
because I was more intelligent than they
were but because I could construct an
Express Express an argument in a way
that they had simply hadn't been trained
to do so the stuff that I said sounded
better right and I found that I've
really carried that through my life I
taught poker seminars for many years and
what I discovered was that if I
conceptually thought something was true
I better be able to explain it really
well and construct a coherent argument
and if I couldn't do that I would
actually go back and rethink the concept
that I thought was true because being
able to translate that so important what
I do when I get up and talk about
behavioral economics to executives I've
got to do the same thing I've got to be
able to description struct that argument
from start to finish to get it to be
understandable to them so that they can
actually learn the lessons of what I'm
trying to teach and I think that that
was so incredibly important is that I
think about argumentation in a way of
you know top thesis sentence what pieces
of evidence am I going to grab
been like what are gonna be my secondary
theses you know and I've got to be able
to support those because I did that for
four years and I think that that was
actually incredibly valuable in both my
communication skills but also in my
critical thinking skills for myself
because it caused me to change the way
that I think about a lot of things when
I recognized that I couldn't construct
one of those arguments it makes you
challenge yourself you have a favorite
book movie or poem about gambling or
about poker really although I mean I
like the Cincinnati kid but I think
that's because I like Steve McQueen more
than because the poker in that really oh
yeah that's the that's the emotional
Robinson by the way I mean I just like
the cast of that there were some yeah
yeah I think what Steve McQueen it's the
emotion overwhelming the frontal cortex
so well that's what we're gonna talk
about Trump briefly and then let's open
it up so you were on the Celebrity
Apprentice you know what we many of us
have heard of Donald Trump what was it
like and I know in past interviews
you've said you know yeah I've been it's
not like you got to know him in any kind
of deep way but that what you see is
what you get what kind of character you
know what kind of character is I mean I
would say what I said in the past
interviews is you know I was asked are
you surprised by what you've seen during
the election having spent some
significant amount of time with him and
my answer is no I
I'm not surprised by it what you saw
when I was on The Apprentice is very
much in line with what I've seen during
the campaign and I think that one of the
things that Trump I really got is how to
create great reality TV I mean the fact
is I wasn't an apprentice watcher before
I went on it and I wasn't an apprentice
watcher after I got off the show it's
not it's just not kind of my deal but I
mean obviously it was a really well
watched show so he was doing something
to get eyeballs on what what is it is it
that is it his projection of confidence
even though he might change what he says
he deeply believes in a moment
but at every time he says it with
absolute conviction and authority um and
then occasionally he'll be like I don't
know you know because when I was an
interesting moment a couple weeks ago
and he was talking with Chris Matthews
on hardball and Chris Matthews was
trying to get him to talk about abortion
and he's like it's got to be illegal and
then Chris Massie says well if it's
illegal should there be punishment for
the woman and he said yeah there has to
be because if it's illegal then there
has to be punishment and Matthew said
what punishment he's like I don't know
but there has to be something so I mean
he's
it's a weird I mean he is both over he
seems overconfident bullying but then
also strangely humbled I mean what you
know what is it about him that you think
is capturing you know possible quite
possibly the Republican nomination well
so first of all I'd like to say that
despite you having said that you shut
the TV up I just found out you do
sometimes watch MSNBC oh no trust me i
watch at all I'm DVR in this whole
weekend so I think actually what you're
touching on is kind of interesting so
let let's just assume for the sake of
argument that you have a person where
the truth is is not important right I'm
not speaking directly to it I'm just
saying just hypothetically you have
someone like that who who is willing to
make statements with great confidence
okay I just told you how beliefs are
form right people hear them they believe
them and then basically once that belief
is form they're looking for confirming
evidence and they're kind of not
noticing things that don't confirm it so
think about actually how in a way
brilliant it is to state opposing sides
of an argument at different times with
great confidence it's it's literally
something for everybody um and now it if
you sort of have a tendency to believe
one thing you go haha see that's
believed and you're not kind of noticing
the other stuff or remember I said
people will do big to mental gymnastics
to actually discredit disconfirming
evidence so it's it's well I don't think
that that would actually get implemented
or I don't think that's actually his
true belief this other thing is the true
belief so in a weird way Trump is
actually an amazing behavioral scientist
right like he
understand intuitively I think something
very deep about the way we form beliefs
and then what we want to kind of hear
back as regards to our beliefs so it's
confusing to people I think who are
analysts and pundants
and trying to get deep down into well
what's the reality right um it's
confusing because you can see so easily
well there's some contradictions there
but to the listeners to the average
person who's listening that's actually
quite brilliant right oh I heard that
you know he's for intervention he's
gonna blow up you know olive Syria and
they're like yes I really like that or
oh he says he's gonna be an isolationist
and he's not gonna get involved oh yes I
really like that and I think he's just
saying the other stuff so that people
who like that will vote for him I don't
really believe that and that's kind of
what you have across the board and and
it's not like this isn't necessarily
unique to Trump you've seen some pivots
right so so Cruz for example a strict
constitutionalist but also may be okay
with Supreme Court justices being voted
out just as an example of something you
know you've seen some from Sanders where
people will stay back Cruz well he
doesn't really mean it when he's talking
about immigration or that's right real
that's not his real belief right so
people say that as well um you know on
the Sanders side I you you hear this
again very similar to Trump repeating of
the same themes over and over again with
great conviction right where he's he's
really implanting that belief in people
right I mean saying just those things
repeatedly again with great force and
great conviction and plants those
beliefs and now people are hearing that
back in a way that feels very good to
them right I mean Clinton obviously has
shifted quite a few to give something
for everyone right so would you say she
in a way I mean certainly Trump and
Sanders have this insurgency going and
it's fascinating that they're actually
independents who have done really well
and in party primaries the parties they
don't even belong to in any real way
Cruz also you know has some energy
Hillary is the presumptive you know in
most polls she would win he's gonna be
the Democratic nominee does she have and
yet she seems to be grading on even her
biggest
and what is she doing something wrong or
is she actually doing something right in
in kind of that bonding moment with the
way she's projecting it's hard to say I
mean I feel a little bit like I don't
know I think that I'm very biased
because I'm a woman
and so I'm bi I think I'm biased towards
saying that like when someone's saying
that her decibel level is loud in a
negative way that well Sanders decibel
level is quite low
Wow right so people don't know that's
what you know so I think that I I wonder
if there's a little bit of a different
standard there I think I think part of
the problem with Clinton is that she's
Clinton so she's been around for a
really long time and I think that
there's a very vocal part of the
electorate that clearly is saying that
they don't want people who are in trend
and have been around for a long time
then who's has a gap is similar to Jeb
Bush you know and you know obviously
there's a balance of experience versus
what's considered sort of entrenchment
and part of the establishment machine
and and sort of what people feel like
it's been hurting them um and I think
that that's what you're finding I think
though that what you'll find is that in
general I think that I'm guessing that
the anger toward the establishment in
the country in general is actually less
than we think it is and I'm not saying
that uh in some ways it's more than we
think it is in the sense that obviously
we have these insurgent candidates but
they're also the loudest voices um and
if you look at the voting in the
Democratic Party despite the fact that
you're getting this huge number of votes
coming for Sanders in the end Clinton's
winning by like three million votes of
people who are bothering to get out for
the primaries who tend to be the more
motivated so the evidence kind of
suggests that yes that's true and
there's definitely a voice for it but
maybe it's not as huge as you think and
certainly I think that's true on the
Republican side I mean there's still a
large majority of Republicans who say
we're not we don't really want that
insurgency right but there's something
called availability bias which is when
you hear something and it's very loud
and very frequent I'm very loud and
so it covered on TV a lot we judge the
frequency to be much higher than it
actually so I would be interested to see
like if you actually could do a real
pull you know what those numbers
actually look like